my auntie who I was very very close to
died at the age of 50. she was very
selfless and by the time she was 50 she
just like started thinking of herself
and then I immediately thought sod this
I don't know when my last day is going
to be so I quit my job sold my house
went traveling spent loads of money come
back homeless I still spent my last bit
of money to educate myself a lot of
people thought I was crazy taking all
these risks and now I'm living to live
not living to survive in one day you
pack into them from scratch and then
sold them making 15 grand in one day so
you're making like 10 15 grand a month
plus your regular service accommodations
how much should I make it between two to
four grand a month this summer it's
expected to be about nine grand net
profits I'm your leaders and Academy
group chats as well I get the most
business from
congratulations on your huge success
thank you I'm sorry to be here you're
making crazy money now in property what
strategies are you using in property at
the minute how are you making all the
money you're making at the moment I'm
using rent to essays I've got free
rental essays at the moment as well as
deal sourcing so I'm selling on average
around three to five deals a month and
how much are you charging for the
average deal average deal three thousand
pounds so you're making like 10 15 grand
a month just from that aspect of your
business on average yes plus your rent
deserves accommodations yes how much are
they making
um it fluctuates but between two to four
grand a month gravy so you're set up
you're done yeah talk to me about how
you got into property and then I want to
go through exactly how you've done it
and maneuver challenges like everybody I
want to go through exactly how you did
it how you overcame the challenges and
hopefully people watching this will be
able to emulate what you've done and
take a lot of life lessons from it so
how did you get into property what
happened I got into property so I
previously had a travel business this
and my latest boyfriend that I had he
saw how hard work and I was and he was
like you said you want to get an Airbnb
you need to go and see Samuel leads he's
amazing and I was like no no it's fine
I'm right where I am and he said no you
need to so then he's like look I've paid
for it you're going you need to go in to
meet Samuel leads so I did finish shout
out to him shout out to him it's amazing
and after that I saw you literally for a
day and thought this I need to be all in
put the money on the table and it was
the best decision I ever made so you
joined the academy yes and you built up
your portfolio slowly over the time one
of the things you're probably well known
for which is one of your greatest
achievements is making 15 grand in one
day yes talk to me about that the
strategy I used to make 15 grand a day
is obviously the quickest deal you can
get over the line which is rent to
essays you don't have to wait three
months on end it's literally a deal
there and it's now so that's the
strategy so if anyone doesn't know what
that is that is when you find a property
where a landlord is prepared to give you
the property not to sell it but to give
you a lease for maybe four or five years
where you then have the correct
contracts where you can rent it out on
Airbnb short stay let's so it's like a
business opportunity yes so you packaged
up a bunch of these in one day you
package them from scratch and then sold
them to who
um I had a few people on my investor
list already but previous the day prior
to before I even got the deal sealed I
had done an Instagram post and everyone
messaged me on my Instagram post so I
called them all up the next day and
that's where all my buyers were formed
they all of them was pretty much new
that's crazy the power of social media
yeah exactly because back in the day
you'd have to travel you know go for
coffees with people and business
networking events but actually social
media is powerful yeah it really is you
get a lot of your business from social
media I do I do get a lot of business
from social media or through Samuel
Lee's Academy group chats you get a lot
of business from there and networking
events as well but I would probably say
Samuel leads Academy group chats is
where I get the most business from
that's great because everyone there is
educated exactly they're all serious and
there's so much business done together
yeah so
um talk me through your first deal so I
think the first deal I ever sold was a
by refurbishal Finance to HMO in Hull it
was a four bedroom HMO that could be
converted into five bedrooms I did
actually co-deal Source at the time
because I didn't have any investors and
once I got that one over the line I
think I did that within six weeks of
being in the academy after the deal
finding Extravaganza and then I just
fell in love with it from then on I was
like right I need to get more deals I
need to sell them on that's amazing and
the interesting thing as well like when
you started I mean when you're in the
academy you didn't have a lot of money
how much did you have after I paid for
the Academy I had six grand six grand
which is not bad it's not shabby but
it's not enough to go buy a house no
definitely not so talk me through some
of the misconceptions because I think a
lot of people think that to get into
property you've got to have you know 50
Grand 60 Grand yeah as a deposit to buy
a house yeah what do you think about
that I don't think that at all I mean at
the time I was really really struggling
I was so for surfing I didn't have a
house um didn't have money obviously I
had some savings and I still made the
jump I still spent my last bit of money
to educate myself because I knew that I
wanted to be a boss I wanted my own
business I didn't want to go back to the
nine to five and I just wanted to run
life how I want to do it so what was
your why my why is my auntie who I was
very very close to died at the age of
50. and she was very selfless done
everything for everyone and by the time
she was 50 she just like started
thinking of herself she got stage four
cancer and passed away and then I
immediately thought this I don't know
when my last day is going to be so I
quit my job sold my house went traveling
spent loads of money and then after that
I was like I'm living life how I want to
live it I don't care what anyone says to
me I'm gonna do it a lot of people
thought I was crazy taking all these
risks but I just didn't care because I
knew whatever I'm doing I know I'm on
the right path now and I'm going to
succeed how I want to no matter how long
it's going to take me so when you got
back from traveling you said you were
homeless yeah what was life like during
that period I was very very depressed a
lot of times never told anyone I was but
I went through some dark moments where I
had to go to therapy but I still in my
head was still fighting because I had
this vision of what I want my end goal
to be like so I don't care that I went
through that struggle I had to go
through that struggle I'm still up and
down with that struggle now but um I
know that I'm gonna get to where I want
to be so you were in a normal job yes
you had a house normal life yep family
member passed away yeah and then you
decided right I'm selling my house and
I'm going traveling yeah I could do a
bad decision it was bad because I should
have invested in something before going
but it was the best decision I ever made
because I've never felt so free and just
I just that was the best feeling I've
ever felt in my life just how long were
you traveling um a year so we went for a
year yeah came back but now you got them
it just came back skin
and depressed and homeless literally my
worst nightmare happened yeah
um but I've got through it I've got
through it and if I can get through it
anyone can get through it what did your
family think when you got into property
and said right I went down Samuel leads
course and I'm part of this community
well some of them knew that I was a bit
depressed and they thought right you're
spending your last bit of money on
Samuel Lee's course
um they thought I was having a midlife
crisis I didn't know what I was doing no
one really believed in me and it just
and that made me more depressed and more
it like made me struggle so much I
thought sod this took myself up north
and just stepped away from everyone done
what I have to do knuckled down and now
I the people can see that I'm actually
getting somewhere and I have got free
rental essays now everyone is really
supportive around me which is amazing
they've seen the yeah they've seen that
I can do it and now they couldn't be
better so how's life changed then over
the last year since you've become
successful in property so how my life
has changed from so what happened to
nine until five I was always in the rat
race coming back home cooking dinner
thinking I'm just paying to live in four
walls I'm not Exploring Life I'm not
living life how I want I'm doing it to
survive
and now I'm living to live not living to
survive and it just feels so much better
I feel free I'm doing what I want to do
and I know that if I got to my deathbed
I'd be happy with what I'm doing because
I'm doing what I want to do and what I
want to achieve in life and you've got
some exciting projects on the go as well
I have yeah talk to you about we'd have
to say where it is but it's a beautiful
area yes um just north of London yes
talk to me about some of the projects
that you've got going on or lined up at
the moment um so I've got a few places
there at the moment and I'm hopefully
taking on a whole brand new development
of 15 Apartments soon I'm really really
excited about it's very exciting yes
it's a banging deal yes it is how do you
build rapport with developers and
landlords how do you get them or
convince them to give you deals to be
fair I think he's just got arms just so
confident in the industry I'm in now and
I will just walk around I'll I think the
two developers that I've got really good
close connections with at the moment
they saw me setting up the Airbnb on my
own so they naturally come over and said
oh do you need a hand because obviously
I'm a small woman on my own trying to
set up an apartment funnily enough they
ended up being two big developers then
they started saying oh I really love
what you're doing would you be able to
do that in my Apartments like I'll be
looking to take someone on like you like
I feel like I can trust you and stuff
like this and because I'm just so
confident speaking in what I do in
business now we're just building up
Rapport like that and just putting
yourself out there really yeah
um you mentioned as well I like to
almost drag you to come on winners on a
Wednesday yeah why was that I don't know
because I just feel like I just want to
achieve so much more and you obviously
show that I am successful and I should
celebrate my little wins because they're
only going to get bigger and bigger so
I'm really excited and happy that you
asked me to come on talk to me about
your experience on the academy and what
it's been like over the last year or so
on the academy it has been absolutely
amazing if I just done one course there
is no way that I would be able to get to
where I am today I don't know how people
do because I feel like being in the
academy being around inspirational
people just helped you grow so much more
on your the networks that you get you
could have investors you can get JV
partners and it's just yeah what will be
your biggest life lesson or business
advice that you would say to yourself
from a couple of years ago when you were
just getting into it I would say stick
to a property patch and stay with that
patch don't go up and down the country I
did for a whole year and I just didn't
know what I was doing I was like oh
developments all commercial to
residential old bra I'll rent to essays
and I'm like my head didn't know where I
was going and then as soon as I I've got
my first rent to essay I just like this
is my patch now and I'm just going to
grow in that area and then hopefully
you're going to build more business
there to combine my Airbnb business as
well and I feel so much better that I'm
in down south in one area what are some
of the skills that you need as a
property entrepreneur in order to get
deals over the line you need training
definitely there's too many people that
has watched one Samuel Lee's video that
think they're fully qualified and
they're really really not you really do
need the training and it's just
confidence just learning more building
finding people that are better than you
in the industry and building rapport
with them it's a big aspect to get you
to where you need to be so if you're
with people that are higher up than you
you're forever going to learn off them
and it's going to help you grow yeah
what are your Visions for the for the
next 12 months then because you've
you're doing deals selling and you're
making like 10 grand plus you're doing
your rent to rent you're financially
independent there yeah what's next for
jodo I want at least 10 more essays and
then I do want to get on to buying
essays
and then my end vision is to do it
overseas so I want to get some essays in
Dubai so that is my end goal do you know
many people doing that because there's
quite a lot of talk in the academy about
you know I'm doing this in Dubai I've
got this but I do I do know a couple of
people that have done it I know a lot of
people with um properties in Dubai we
actually have some properties in Dubai
that we're selling at the moment So
eventually when I can I want to go over
there as well because it's a really
really good area for Investments how
important do you think it is as well
environment because we're at the
accelerated coaching performance program
last week yeah last night and it was
like there was about I don't know how
many people 25 people all around the
room in my in one of my houses and it's
like everybody's doing deals yeah
literally I don't think there was one
person that wasn't making money and it
was quite normal oh I'm back in 10 grand
I'm making 20 grand a month I'm making
30 grand a month or and it's like wow
and I think if you're not doing deals
you almost feel like the odd one out
it's almost like positive peer pressure
yeah how important do you think that
aspect is in order to be successful
having been around other people that are
winning I think it's
found it so inspiring I'm like
I'm never jealous of someone doing
better than me I always find them as
someone that can teach me or they would
inspire me to think right they can do it
I can definitely get that far yeah and
being in that environment this week was
just incredible and we get to be close
together and hopefully help each other
grow your first deal that was bar
refurbatory Finance
to HMO in Grimsby it's interesting
because you're using a lot of different
strategies you use you know linking by
refurbish to HMO rent to rent service
accommodation all these different
strategies that are linking what is it
about you as a deal source that you
think is different to other people why
do you think people come to you for
deals what's your unique selling point I
suppose I'm very far in the work that I
carry out
um I make investors feel comfortable
with the Investments they're going to be
invested in you know because there's a
lot of people out there that think oh
you can only get capital gains and you
show them that no you can get a lot of
cash flow as well from properties and
obviously I've got properties myself and
when people see that I've got properties
myself that shows oh then she must know
what she's doing I want to get involved
with her and a lot of people have once I
showed that the rental essays that I've
put up for example everyone's now right
I want you to help me I want you to help
me grow and a lot of people want to join
Venture with me as well that's great
success Bridge more success doesn't it
yeah it really does and some of your
rent to rent are absolutely popping into
all your best months of some of the
properties uh my best months maybe with
one of them it was four grand net profit
just from one property for one property
yeah this summer this expected to be
about
eight grand nine grand net profit
especially with uh some events that are
coming up like it's already booked out
so I know what profit I'm gonna get how
do you keep an eye on the conferences
coming up and changing the prices and
all that sort of stuff so I use price
Labs which is an absolute godsend
beforehand I was doing it all manually
and I was just like oh my God this is
really irritating to keep up with it all
because you can't keep up with them
about price laps and how that helps with
your business class Labs helps
tremendously so you can link it up and
it will literally with the algorithms in
the system it will go up and down
depending on the events throughout the
year all right I'll tell you how to
price it it just does it automatically
you link it up and the algorithms will
then sync there's so many hacks like
that isn't there yeah and if you don't
know it you can mess up your pricing
because you might oh exactly you
suddenly get booked up for a week and
you think oh good but then you realize
that there's yeah a German Christmas
Market going on there and actually you
should have charged triple yeah exactly
that has happened to me before I've
charged 100 pounds a night and then I've
rung someone in the area and they're
like Jody cancel it you can charge 700
pounds a night this week no because the
change is massively it does and you've
really got to keep an eye on it because
you could yeah and another thing is as
well with service accommodation is
sometimes you can have a few good months
where you make like three grand three
grand from one property and you think oh
my gosh oh it's passive now but then
it's like no no this is just a good
season yeah you know the next season you
you're making 500 quid yeah so it is
very much you need to really understand
the market and projections you do and
look at service accommodation as an
annual thing rather than a monthly thing
because it does change and it can
fluctuate quite a lot I think that's an
important Point talk to me a little bit
about that it's it's so important to
keep
to keep finances each month I've only
just in
these and what money I'm making I mean
because one property I thought I was
doing it so well and then I'm like oh
I'm only earning 100 pounds a month on
that property because I wasn't keeping
track and upping my prices like I should
have been yeah but now we've connected
price Labs that's changed and I am
learning a lot more from that property
but it's just so important to keep on
track because if you're not making money
from one property get rid of it yeah and
then move on to the next one yeah
exactly and it's a constant checking in
checking the kpis what would be your
greatest piece of advice for somebody
watching this that's wanting to become
financially free like yourself in
property I would say a hundred percent
get the training immediately I wouldn't
have been able to do what I'm doing now
without your training so if you are
looking to get the skills and get be a
property entrepreneur you need to be
trained I would agree people sometimes
that they're not prepared to invest even
a pound in themselves they're not
prepared to put a day aside learning but
they want to reap all the benefits yeah
but you've got to invest in yourself
even if it's just a pound come to a
crash course have your eyes open exactly
but like you say if you don't pay you
don't pay attention and that's so true
I've been on courses before that have
been nothing and I don't pay attention
because I didn't pay for it because I
paid for this I was like I need to be
successful because I need to get my
money back everybody and also everybody
in the room is like I'll pay thousands
for this yeah but when you've got a
group of people they're all like this
has to work yeah and then you've got
good teachers like myself and mentors
going let's make this work yeah it's the
ingredients for Success exactly because
it goes back to environment so that's
awesome well Jody massive
congratulations on your success thank
you and I don't know this is just the
beginning so I look forward to seeing
what you all continue to achieve and
thanks for coming on the show thank you
very much
foreign
[Music]